learn to use three js shaders by the end
of this tutorial
you should have a pretty good idea of
what shaders are and how you can write
your own
in 3js so if you're unfamiliar with
shaders i'm just going to go over a
bunch of terms real quick
feel free to skip ahead if you just want
to know how to do this in 3js
so shaders there are these tiny
fragments of code that run
on the gpu and they're pretty neat
because you can use them to do pretty
extensive modifications to the mesh or
the final color
now there's basically two types of
shaders supported in 3gs
those being vertex shaders and fragment
shaders quick reminder
make sure you're subscribed so you get
more content like this in the future
back to shaders so the way they work is
let's say this is the screen
so i'll draw this rectangular area and
that's the screen
and i want to draw this triangle on the
screen well a triangle is made of three
vertices
and then there's the actual pixels that
appear on the screen as a result
each of these vertices we run a small
program called a vertex shader
and that's responsible for doing basic
stuff like transforming the vertex from
world space to screen space
as well as passing along anything like
texture coordinates to the pixel
at each pixel we run another separate
program called a fragment shader or
pixel shader
depending on what source you're reading
and that's responsible for doing things
like looking up the texture color
mixing it with the triangle's color
doing that kind of thing
and finally outputting a color for the
screen together they form a shader
program
and this is what you bind when you're
drawing things like meshes
now i'll cover some quick terminology as
with any program there are a few ways to
set up parameters or customize a shader
program
you might have two different meshes both
with the same shader program
but given different parameters to get
different results
there's kind of global parameters or in
webgl terms these are called uniforms
and if you think about a shader program
consisting of both a vertex and fragment
shader
uniforms are things you set globally and
are available in either
imagine on the first mesh for example
you might set a uniform called diffuse
texture with one texture
and on the second one you might set a
different texture
then there are attributes and these you
don't really set yourself they're part
of the mesh data itself and are only
accessible by the vertex shader
this gives the vertex shader the chance
to do any manipulation of the data
including transforming the position of
each vertex
lastly we have varyings and this is like
a communication pipe between the vertex
shader and the fragment shader
they're slightly difficult to understand
so i'll step through a basic example
say you have this triangle here with
three vertices at each of these three
vertices the gpu is going to run your
vertex program
which will transform in output positions
let's say that each vertex also
outputs a varying so at vertex 1 we'll
output a color value of 1
0 0 or red at vertex 2 we'll output 0 1
0 or green and at vertex 3 we'll output
0
0 1 or blue now this triangle is also
made up of a whole bunch of pixels
so let's just pick one at random and
look at how the fragment shader works
at every one of these pixels the gpu
will also run the fragment shader
and as you know it has access to the
uniform values but it also has access to
the varying values from the vertex
shader
so this pixel is part of the triangle
formed by these three vertices
and those three vertices provided three
different varying values
what happens is those values will get
interpolated across the triangle
and the fragment shader at any given
pixel will get the interpolated value
okay so we're all set let's code this up
in 3js your main
entry point to getting your own custom
shaders going is by using this class
here called shader material
and we can take a quick look at the docs
here as it mentions here
it's a material designed to be rendered
with custom shaders
there's some other info here about
gotchas and things to consider
mostly minor things that probably won't
affect us
i'm just going to scroll down the page
to the section on using the shader
material class
so from the example here usage is
straightforward
you need to supply three things a chunk
of code representing the fragment shader
a chunk of code representing the vertex
shader and a dictionary of uniform
values that you have to supply
and keep in mind these are just the
custom ones you declare there's also a
whole bunch of built-in ones
if i scroll down a bit and i click on
this webgl program link
webgl program declares a whole bunch
that 3gs kind of magically just sets for
you without you needing to worry about
supplying them
here's a complete list you can see here
that the vertex shader has a bunch that
are usually important for transforming
positions and normals
so you've got the worldview and
projection matrices as well as a
combined one just to save you from
having to multiply them yourselves in
the shader
you've got a couple others here that can
be useful like normal matrix and camera
position
you've also got some attributes that you
don't have to declare yourself
things like position normal and uv are
declared for you if you use shader
material
the code to declare these is
concatenated onto your code before it's
all compiled
so it's all there down a bit further you
can see that the fragment shader also
has a couple uniforms that you can
access
if you need them now as a small aside
you can also use raw shader material the
other way to define custom shaders in
3gs
it won't add any built-in uniforms and
attributes you just
get exactly what you wrote let's code
some examples up
we'll create a new directory for this
shader project we'll call it 3gs
tutorial shaders once that's done i'm
going to copy a previous project in here
because i don't feel like writing all
the boilerplate to get started
so a quick copy of the basic 3d world
project should get us going
if you haven't had a chance to check
that out go now since it explains all of
the setup
anyway once that's done we're in the
code here and i'm going to define a few
basic objects in the scene
i'll start with two spheres and a ground
plane so we already have a ground plane
from the project
what i need to do now is to find two
spheres and that's pretty easy
all you have to do is instantiate a
three dot mesh and as a parameter you
need to pass in a sphere geometry and a
material
i'm going to set the material color to
white to start
we also need to make sure to set the
position so i've set it using
position.set
and i'll make this first sphere a little
bit down to the left on the x-axis
lastly just add it to the scene now a
quick copy paste with this chunk of code
so we can make a second sphere
and i'll reuse all of the same
parameters for now white material blah
blah blah
only difference is i'm going to set this
one a little bit to the right on the
x-axis
so now we've got this simple scene ready
to try some shaders out
as you can see we've got two spheres and
a ground plane back in the code i'm
going to go to the second sphere here
and this is what we're going to change
to our own material
so the second parameter the one that's
mesh standard material
it's getting swapped for shader material
and now we need to pass in a few params
so i'm going to pass in an empty
uniforms and then i'm going to pass some
stuff in for the fragment and vertex
shaders and although i haven't written
these out yet
i'll just apply two names and of course
we'll go and define them afterwards
often i find it's easier to write the
code as if things exist and then go back
and actually make them exist
so let's scroll to the top here and what
i'll do is define both vertex shader and
fragment shader
if you're not familiar with glsl i
suggest finding and reading some
tutorials on it
it's a simple language very c-like
vector types mostly
but if you're familiar with javascript
you can probably get the gist of what
i'm writing here
what i'm doing is transforming the point
from local space by the worldview
projection matrices
the vertex shader is super simple not
doing anything else the fragment shader
is going to be equally simple
all that i'll do here is to find the
main and then we'll output a constant
color
so that means that i just need to assign
a vect4 to glfrag color
and i'll make this output red to begin
with which is one zero zero
and one for the alpha and that should be
it load this up and what do you know
red sphere on the right left one is the
same as before
but what's interesting here is that the
red sphere is actually running our
custom shader we can literally put
anything into that code and it'll show
up on the sphere
i'll run through a few more quick
examples so let's go back into the code
and we're going to modify the vertex
shader a bit
just to show what can be done here so
let's take the sphere
and what i'm going to do is multiply the
x axis by 4
stretching the whole thing out so we
need to multiply the incoming position
by 4
1 1 before we apply the rest of the
transform
when i load that up look how stretched
out this is
what i'm showing you is that these
shaders can modify both the final color
that's emitted
or the actual mesh itself can be mutated
programmatically
let's go and undo that now because we
don't really need it but i'll give you
an example of a varying attribute that
you pass through from the vertex shader
to the fragment shader
what i'm going to do is pass the spheres
normal through the varying attribute
so i just need to declare a new varying
we can call it v normal
and inside the main function we need to
assign the normal to the varying
now we make the same modification to the
fragment shader so we scroll down here
and just do the same thing
declare a new variant called v normal
and it's important they have the same
name
now we can just use it however we want
inside the fragment shader in this case
i'm going to replace the color output
with the normal meaning we're going to
visualize the normals
so just assign it to glfrag color also
notice since gl frag color is a vec4
we need to turn v normal into a vector
from vect3
okay load this up and it's kind of
colorful what you're seeing is a visual
representation of the normal directions
if you were to pick any color on the
sphere write out the values
you'd get a unit vector representing the
normal quick pro tip i've spent years as
a professional graphics programmer on
major xbox playstation games and often
when i'm debugging things that have gone
wrong in shaders
i may output the colors directly like
i'm doing here to visualize them and see
where things might have gone wrong
okay last cheesy demo let's create a
uniform that we'll set from code
first thing we'll comment out the gl
frag color lines since we don't want to
visualize the normals anymore
and would declare a new vec4 uniform at
the top let's call it sphere color
we'll also change the code so that we
output sphere color directly into gl
frag color
now to actually set it from code we need
to go over to the declaration of the
shader material
and you see that we had a uniform stick
here before but it was an empty dick
since we had nothing to add but now
we're going to define a new one so we
need to add it here
you just need to add a key value with
the same name so it was called sphere
color in the fragment shader
so we called it sphere color here and
we'll set the value to blue
so instantiate a new three dot vector
three and give it value
zero zero one that should be good to go
load it up and we're seeing a blue
sphere
but you don't have to just set the value
once and forget about it you can set it
every frame if you want
what we can do is add a quick variable
let's call this total time
and we'll use this to accumulate some
time in the step function so
let's go down to the step function what
we'll do is change the color over time
so first we need to accumulate the time
and total time and once we've done that
we can run it through a sine function
what this will do is over time
the value will bounce back and forth
between negative one and one
and then we just need to use it for
something also note since the sine value
gives a range of negative one to one you
have to multiply by 0.5 and add 0.5
just to put it in the range 0 to 1. so
let's declare two colors here we'll just
call them c1 and c2
and we're just going to set these to red
and green respectively
now 3gs allows you to use either a
3.color or a 3 dot vector 3.
i'll use a 3 vector 3 since i already
used that previously
then we'll create an interpolated value
by creating a third variable which is
just lurping between
c1 and c2 using the value we computed
next i just accessed the uniform value
from the material
and assigned it there that's all it
takes to update a value and we should be
able to see it live
now if you load this up the color ping
pongs back and forth between red and
green
and that's it that should get you
started obviously there's a lot more to
writing shaders and if you're looking
for ideas of effects or cool things you
can do
i hardly recommend visiting a site like
shader toy because it's just absolutely
full of good ideas
code's all up on github so check it out
if you're stuck or just want to look it
over
otherwise until next time cheers
you